yeah
yeah
[Music]
so in this talk we're gonna combine all
the things we learned today my
webassembly has been mentioned several
times today and the goal of this talk is
to get you writing web assembly modules
tomorrow and the weekend for your
projects or maybe at work on Monday a
bit about me
Vlad I'm coming from Toronto Canada I'm
a full-stack engineer at Mozilla I well
I work on Firefox and my day-to-day is
working with is working with JavaScript
and rust so you'll probably already
heard about web assembly today it's a
new new low-level bytecode for the web
it's a stack based virtual machine and
it produces these azam files and it's
used for calculations computational
tasks importing low-level libraries
multimedia processing game development
and a lot of Bitcoin mining good thing
though it integrates well with the web
developer workflow there's been a survey
done this year but usage is a
webassembly on the rigging the top top
alexa web sites and the result was that
it's used for mining a lot but also for
good things like libraries gaming and
other kind of custom code meanwhile this
morning I nobody mentioned it I think in
in their slides but webassembly is now
officially a web standard so it's a huge
yeah claps for all the developers
contributors browser vendors we kind of
we made it now it's the fourth language
that's on the web it allows to run code
in the web browser and yeah I tweet it
just 9 a.m. I was just like yes you can
go read the details and even though we
just standardized it it's already here
and it's ready for you to use there's an
easy way to to integrate web assembly in
your applications for instance some
libraries like Pico the high quality
image resizer has this amazing way of
integrating
assembly all you have to do is to pass
the wasm string into the options and
beaker is ready to optimize and resize
your images in your apps with we web
assembly so preparing for this talk I
took all the images from the dodgiest
website 130 of them mostly speaker faces
and resized images it took me over 2
seconds with pika then I forced the web
assembly mode on it and it took less
than a second to process all those
images so very easy to use you can you
can get on that but we want to go and
optimize our own applications and our
projects and sometimes you get this
sense where maybe power users or some
like if somebody's really have a using
your application it starts to slow down
and maybe it's processing a lot of data
processing images video and things like
that so we have this problem that it's a
bit slow on the computation size and
here's a quick example of that we have
some application that computes things
then there's this gear icon to start
spinning and then we get the output and
I want to take this example in my
example here to hash strings and what
I'm doing here is I'm using this 2 X
hash algorithm to hash the string a
hundred thousand of times and there's an
implementation of it on NPM you can
download it check it out
and what I want to do is I want to speed
this up because right now it takes
around over two seconds yeah almost
three seconds there sometimes it's been
slower to run this hashing operation and
in your heads I just want you to kind of
think about your application when I see
when you see the slide what's what's the
kind of where's my computing logic
happening what can I substitute here
that's taking time I think in Charlie's
example this morning she was doing the
the audio processing so we can switch
this gear and put the audio processing
on that into a web assembly module so
then we need to decide how can we what
can we use to ride this webassembly
module in and in this slide that's kind
of that's my order of preference here
right now which is first I'm going to go
to rust if it can do it if not then I
will
or the assembly script see if that can
do it and maybe the CC C++ C is the is
the other solution and for you you can
just visit the web a sandwich studio
today it will give you this pop-up that
will show you kind of give you choices
of how these Weiser modules look like
when you use these different
technologies and so here's our goal
we're gonna replace replace this gear
icon with whether it was a module and
we've seen webpack mentioned on at this
conference a lot so web pack is kind of
the way to here we go let's try this
again so we have web pack that can do
this for us
it was an amazing module called Watson
pack that will create a rust crate for
you and we'll let you optimize your your
application so when we use resin pack it
creates a rust crate for us already to
be used and we can improve we can import
the 2x hash version of the rust version
of this algorithm into our into our
crate and then a simple function to same
as JavaScript we have an input string
and we've run the hasher on the string
and we output it as hex format in this
case you'll be rewriting this your heavy
computational logic here in rust and
finally in web pack all we have to do
with wasn't back we include a plug-in
that there wasn't back plugging over
there which will build our rust code for
us and as it's as easy as just doing a
new wasn't pack plug-in and pointing it
at the direction of our rust code and
what you'll see yeah and then we can
import the bundle that produces and then
we can run the module functions that we
wrote in rust so we have a 2x hash there
an input and we run it a hundred
thousands of times what I'm doing here
nothing another kind of approach that I
take when I work with these things I
tried to measure all this you saw in my
slide there like I wanted to measure how
long the column pika takes to resize
images how
long it takes right now to do my
computation logic and as I do
performance up now on that and my
[ __ ] workflow here doesn't change I
still do NPM start it this time it
compiles my Russ code as well so no like
additional changes to my build scripts
it does automatically and now I can
activate my web assembly module and now
it's takes 200 milliseconds to perform
the same operation so then I can spin on
the gear it is so fast I had to tweak it
so it slows down a bit so you can see
the animation the other approach here we
want to make sure we use web workers
with web assembly and I've seen examples
of this right now creating abstractions
like create Watson worker pass it past
the dura the source was a module and
then work with it and this sort of looks
like this where we have the web worker
isolation here and the web worker runs
web assembly and performs the
computation there and it will look very
similar now we have a worker GS file
same same code with web workers we have
to use messaging so I have to post
message my result of my hashing to the
original application and this is just
the simplest way to kind of trigger that
and when I write when the message
arrives I run the the computation of
logic in my in my application I can
initialize a new worker with the work of
J's file and send it some messages and
say okay here's the string I want to
hash and in this case again I'm
measuring the performance like and to
see if if adding web workers slows down
my-my-my speed the 200 milliseconds that
I gained with web assembly and there's
some cool spinning classes for for the
CSS to spin if we look at web pack still
same thing we just week our
configuration a bit we now had an app
configuration file we're still reusing
the same plugin but now we have two
configurations we have the application
original application and now we have
this worker web pack target says the set
the target as web worker and we reuse
the same plugin and same nothing changes
there
we can take a look at Firefox I have two
tabs open one with web worker one
without and same speed - hi / around
around 200 milliseconds to measure that
and in Firefox dev tools we can take a
look at the there was a module right
there load it as a as part of the web
worker so why would we want to use web
workers if we compare we would like we
could compare the web worker versus not
a web worker scenario so I'm gonna do my
million hashing application iterations
now in both cases in my old original
example and the web worker example and
we can run it so this is the first one
is going to be the the old example and I
activity webassembly computed and it
takes a while and I tried to right-click
in the browser and my browser is just
locked up because it's not inside a web
worker all this computation is done on
kind of the main thread in my in my web
worker example I can right click the
browser is accessible still kind of the
average is for a million operations now
we're at to around two seconds now I
also want to talk about a bit about the
future of of assembly and where this is
all going there's a lot of kind of span
mentioned a lot of proposals and support
in there another kind of issue tip is
what's called the bytecode Alliance and
it was just announced last month so it's
really really fresh and the bytecode
Alliance is kind of the open source
community it is dedicated to create a
new secure software software foundations
through web assembly and they have
several initiatives and you can read
them about more on the URL there but the
ones I'm excited about our the web
assembly system interfaces and this will
allow us to run web assembly outside
it's going to beyond beyond the web
browser and so this will allow us to
four already fast languages like rust
and
C++ it can introduce better security
models for those languages and runtimes
like Python and know Jesus and maybe
Danno we can use use the web assembly
speed as well as the the security
improvements and it would look something
like this my slide there
the future of this is we we start with
the rust crate that does are for example
2x hash computation later on a rasp
program can import you can import that
code is a rust grade but it can also
import that a web assembly module that
we run as part of a rust program and
then we have kind of the top there's
that Firefox loads webassembly you've
seen an example of that already but for
example Python can load the same web
assembly module and also load one from
assembly script and the Python program
outputs the terminal but also it exports
to a node.js server and this week there
was a post about dotnet being a being
able to use and load these modules as
well so you can see how flexible the
future can be here another besides kind
of loading these these crates these
modules the web of sanity modules in
different ways we can also the the
bytecode Alliance is working on a new
kind of nano process security model and
I think that was kind of I think that
the demo talk Bert mentioned is where
they have permissions for networking and
kind of sandboxing things so the Nano
process security model is basically in a
single slide this is what would look
like we have a rust grade and it could
be the two x hash that we just I saw a
you saw an example of export is the one
but suddenly module however it has its
own memory sandbox and for instance it
can have a network access for and then
it can be imported in the Python program
that also provides a web assembly module
but this time that uh basura module only
has file system access and with j/s we
can also extend box memory and finally
import that import that all into the
node.js process and for instance if I
have an OG Apple
and my 2x hash crate updates and I'm
just kind of doing cargo update or
updating my dependencies I don't know if
like there's gonna be something
malicious in there or not in this case I
can be confident that if if I give the
2x hash and network access it will have
it but it won't have file system access
so and same with the memory if they will
not corrupt my memory because it's
running in its own sandbox memory case a
quick demo of the webassembly system
interfaces just to see this in action we
have the same code that I showed in the
beginning there the 2x hash nothing
changes here as far yeah it's the same
thing we just build it a bit differently
with in webpack to make the to make this
work in in my front-end application I
changes I change it to use the wisdom
interfaces types loader at some point
probably in webpack this will go away
and it will just work in my application
works the same way so I go back and like
in this case it's so fast to compute
this what I can do now is I've built
this module and for instance for maybe
your production work you want to reuse
the computation that you wrote in other
ways you want for example you have a
Python notebook that needs to import the
same computation and do some metrics on
your code so or or maybe another Russ
program in the wrasse program we can
just load the file to hash that wasum
yeah there we go and we can build and
run the application and it provides the
hash for us in zero point zero seven
seconds in a Python program same thing
just import to hash to hash is just the
one file that I've built just a similar
way I showed you and we can compute
another thing so now we can run this web
assembly module in the Python context
and we just do pi at the old Python
Rhonda py same thing produces a hash now
we have a different string but very
flexible for us to kind of reuse these
modules finally my favorite example is
running this a node.js
we import compute from to hash that
wisdom and compute another another
string you can just console.log it and
now we can kind of move this to hash to
hashing logic that we
we used in that web back fronting
application onto the backend to use this
right now you need a node version 12 or
node version
13 with some experimental Flags and we
run the program the same way and it will
provide us the same the same output
there boom another hash so you can see
the flexibility of kind of reusing these
we're using this code that you've
optimized and now have as part of your
project so just to conclude here use web
assembly wisely you saw I was
benchmarking kind of almost everything
adding new adding workers to to my
front-end application measuring it on
different inputs and use web workers one
important thing to highlight here is
that what the reason I'm measuring all
this is because webassembly might not
always be kind of a solution for this so
if you have a large input like maybe you
have a huge book that you're getting the
process and you take this and you front
an application and you said you're
processing web assembly module all that
input has to travel to the web assembly
module and allocate memory and things
like that so it's like it could not be
the solution that's the reason why I
keep an eye on your output size so there
are several optimizations you can do you
some of the there's some web back
plugins that lets you measure like your
bundle size and keep an eye on the size
of the Yser modules because you can
tweak a single flag in the kind of the
module building step and it will
optimize your your size of the Optio put
so that's a good one and research
different ways in run time so once you
actually write your first wasn't great
or was a module try to run it in
different environments maybe run node.js
in which you can later use for testing
or in Python and things like that and
try to go beyond the web browser it's
gonna it's a very exciting time right
now to kind of reuse this format and
follow follow the news they're cool and
that's it for me thanks so much for
attending this talk and I'll go
organizers
[Applause]
[Music]